[Music]
[Music]
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for educators
they're already talking about this is
the nobel for teachers for surprise for
teaching excellence million dollar prize
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done is to reawaken the world's
appreciation of the importance of
teachers
when each of us thinks about what we can
do in life chances are we can do it
because of the teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change our
world for the better
being a great teacher requires
resilience ingenuity and a generous
heart all of you who are the finalists
in this year's global teacher prize
congratulations
[Music]
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers to transform
students lives a good teacher holds the
power to influence inspire and shape a
young person's life for the better
the winner
is ranjit desali from india
[Music]
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes are teachers
they're the ones that changed
[Music]
[Music]
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for educators
they're already talking about this is
the nobel for teachers for surprise for
teaching excellence million dollar prize
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done is to reawaken the world's
appreciation of the importance of
teachers
when each of us thinks about what we can
do in life chances are we can do it
because of the teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change our
world for the better
being a great teacher requires
resilience ingenuity and a generous
heart all of you who are the finalists
in this year's global teacher prize
congratulations
[Music]
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers to transform
students lives a good teacher holds the
power to influence inspire and shape a
young person's life for the better
the winner
is ranjit desali from india
[Music]
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes are teachers
they're the ones that changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for educators
they're already talking about this is
the nobel for teachers for surprise for
teaching excellence million dollar prize
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done is to reawaken the world's
appreciation of the importance of
teachers
when each of us thinks about what we can
do in life chances are we can do it
because of the teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change our
world for the better
being a great teacher requires
resilience ingenuity and a generous
heart all of you who are the finalists
in this year's global teacher prize
[Music]
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers to transform
students lives a good teacher holds the
power to influence inspire and shape a
young person's life for the better
the winner
is ranjit desali from india
[Music]
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes are teachers
they're the ones that changed
[Music]
[Music]
the global teaching process award is
considered the nobel for educators
they're already talking about this is
the nobel for teachers for surprise for
teaching excellence million dollar prize
recognizing an outstanding contribution
the most important thing this prize has
done is to reawaken the world's
appreciation of the importance of
teachers
when each of us thinks about what we can
do in life chances are we can do it
because of the teacher
they spark curiosity within a child and
nurture the dreams that can change our
world for the better
being a great teacher requires
resilience ingenuity and a generous
heart all of you who are the finalists
in this year's global teacher prize
congratulations
[Music]
like all of you our foundation believes
in the power of teachers to transform
students lives
a good teacher holds the power to
influence inspire and shape a young
person's life for the better
the winner
is ranjit desali from india
[Music]
i can tell you right now from where i
stand with all my experience the real
superheroes are teachers
they're the ones who changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bonjour and welcome to paris
wherever you are in the world we welcome
you to the seventh global teacher prize
ceremony we are absolutely thrilled that
the city of paris has been chosen to
host this very special tribute to the
world's teachers
it was right here in paris in the early
18th century that the age of
enlightenment began with its bold ideas
spreading fast in the salons of our
capital
our world today just as back then
is confronting many great challenges
so once again we need to open our minds
to new ways of thinking so we can face
the future with confidence
it is now my great pleasure to introduce
you to the director general of unesco
miss audrey azule
speaking to you from the unesco
headquarters at the plaza de fuego in
paris
merci isabel and thank you to everyone
for joining us today to support the most
fundamental of professions teaching
i welcome you to unesco house the united
nations home for education culture
science and information
our organization is founded on the
belief that all of us here share that
education can change the world and build
peace that is why unesco is a proud
partner of the global teacher prize
today we will celebrate the work of an
exceptional teacher who has changed many
lives
through this prize we will also
celebrate the work of the 100 million
other teachers and educators around the
world
on the front lines of the pandemic they
have worked with dedication and
inventiveness to ensure that learning
never stops
teachers are the bedrock of our
societies therefore we must put them at
the heart of the recovery
this means holding them in higher esteem
paying them better and training them
better
making the profession more attractive is
essential today
when the world needs an additional 69
million teachers to achieve the goal of
quality education for all by 2030
only by backing teachers today we can
protect our tomorrow thank you very much
and enjoy this ceremony merci
it's not possible for children any
longer to just understand their own
communities they need to understand the
world
[Music]
[Music]
whenever i'm working with young people
my goal is to be able to give them the
tools that they need to be masters of
their own destiny
[Music]
my calling in life is to make sure that
every single child reaches their full
potential that i unlock that
to be a great teacher you have to be
creative embrace technology you really
have to promote those modern ways of
teaching you have to do more and talk
less
i just wanted to create a learning
environment for every student girls
education is more than just getting them
in the school it's more about feeling
safe in the community in the society
it is my absolute joy to host this
year's global teacher prize ceremony
in particular
i feel honored to host this ceremony
from unesco's headquarters an
organization that fights to protect our
most precious values
education
culture and freedom of expression
we have seen how these values bring
people together and inspire hope
something we can all aspire to
our message is very simple
hope always begins with education
which is why this year we are for the
very first time
shining a light on both teachers and
their students
today
as well as announcing the winner of the
global teacher prize we will also
announce the winner of the new check.org
global student prize
both these prizes have been launched to
highlight the importance of education in
tackling the challenges ahead
i would now like to introduce miss
stefania giannini assistant director
general for education at unesco
thank you isabel i'm here in the unesco
library which like so many libraries
around the world has been shut during
the
pandemic sadly we have seen 1.6 billion
learners around the world affected by
the kaveed
and yet students everywhere have shown
great strength
focus determination to keep learning and
keep fighting for the future well they
deserve huge praise and recognition for
never giving up
which is why we are thrilled to see the
launch of the new global student prize
which will recognize their extraordinary
force
but for every student to realize their
full potential
they of course need a great teacher
covenanting has given us all a chance to
pose and reflect
we have learned many things we'll learn
who and what matters most to us
there is perhaps now a small window of
opportunity for the next generation to
make a better world that the one that
inherited
if we back our teachers and we back our
students then together they can remake
the future with greater equality peace
and justice and slowly amid the storm
clouds they will be able to look up and
see blue skies once again thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
my philosophy is that the classroom is a
microcosm of the world and the world is
your classroom
is
as a young energy enthusiast
i wanted to bring a sustainable energy
system that can stop the overuse of
natural resources
i co-create a system to increase big
production to business areas of
developing countries
a close friend of mine and i decided to
take this community service class that
was all about just doing something
positive for your community
when we launched there was four people
on our team and now equal works with
over 100 people day to day on our
operations
service of of self is the core of
everything i do i've used my voice to
get parliamentary receptions and the
articles for the united nations prime
reports or to create a national
conversation around student hardship and
sustainability
[Music]
i will not rest until i make sure that
i'm leaving this world more equal than i
came into it before
empowering a woman is empowering the
whole community that is as
what has led to me building my passion
using my source of empowerment my
knowledge and experience to make sure
that my community is a safe space
i have been able to empower over 225 000
people especially young people across 25
countries planned more than 300 000
trees across the world over 7 000
mangroves helping to rebuild ecosystems
i have been able to pay the school fee
for three of my cousins
through coaching and leading workshops
as well
i have led workshops on menstruation
personal hygiene child marriage domestic
violence
i want to help other girls realize their
abilities as well
one thing that defines me is that i am a
passionate advocate for women's and
girls right
we are the leaders of today
[Music]
now we come to the moment where we
celebrate those who hold the future in
their hands
and make no mistake
young people today have a lot to
accomplish
they are the first truly global citizens
and can affect real change if they are
given the right support
to introduce the check.org global
student prize
i would like to welcome dan rosenswag
the ceo and president of chegg
[Music]
for years we at chegg have known how
incredible students are
and that is why
we were absolutely thrilled to partner
with the varkey foundation to create the
new chegg.org global student prize to
show the whole world how amazing they
are and the fantastic work they are
doing
while many stakeholders are busy
debating students all around the world
are busy doing
most importantly
we launched this prize to showcase their
stories understand their struggles and
hear their voices
after all it is their dreams that will
build our future
in our inaugural year we had an
incredible 3500
applications and nominations from 94
countries around the world
students who applied were being assessed
on everything from their academic
achievement to how they make a
difference in their community to how
they harness their creativity and
innovation to make real change
after months of deliberation we
announced the top 50 shortlist and then
a final 10.
so now it is my pleasure to introduce
the top 10 finalists of the global
student prize
2021
they come from brazil
canada
india
italy
kenya nigeria sierra leone united arab
emirates the united kingdom and the
united states it is my absolute honor to
welcome all of you to this ceremony
congratulations
and welcome
each of you
have made a huge impact in areas from
the environment to equality and justice
to ending poverty
all of your stories deserve to be
celebrated and we look forward to seeing
how you will continue to shape the world
for the better i wish you all the very
best of luck and now we come to a very
special moment
i am delighted to introduce actor and
humanitarian mr hugh jackman to announce
the winner of the inaugural chegg.org
global student prize
thank you dan and all the team at chegg
for everything you do for students
in 2019 which now seems a lifetime ago i
was incredibly proud to host the global
teacher prize ceremony and announce the
winner it was a wonderful celebration of
the teaching profession a cause that is
very close to my own heart
and i'm now absolutely thrilled to be
welcomed back to speak to you again and
this year i'm particularly excited to be
part of announcing the winner of the new
chegg.org global student prize which
spotlights the achievements of
extraordinary students around the world
this prize could not be more timely
students everywhere are fighting for
their very future
they are part of a generation that are
on the front line of the greatest
challenges of our time from climate
change to global inequality so we must
listen to their voices and shine a light
on their stories to every dedicated
student around the world working hard to
build a brighter future we thank you for
everything you do while still pursuing
your education
and now we come to the moment where we
announce the winner of the global
student prize 2021
where we honor one exceptional student
that has made a real impact on learning
the lives of their peers and on society
beyond someone who will use this
platform to give voice to the students
all over the world and of course
with the title comes one hundred
thousand dollar award
so i am delighted to announce that the
winner of the inaugural chegg.org global
student prize
is jeremiah thuranka from sierra leone
congratulations jeremiah you've made an
enormous difference to your community
and far beyond i'm sure that you will
now use this incredible platform to make
an even bigger impact on behalf of all
of us we wish you the very best of luck
so jeremiah that was uh hugh jackman who
wanted to let you know personally that
congratulations my friend you are the
actual winner
of the chegg.org student prize
and a hundred thousand dollars
how do you feel my friend i feel amazing
i feel like i'm so much hopeful for what
i do
it's amazing it's wonderful
words can't express how i feel you know
about this
congratulations i mean just thank you
for being you and for what you're doing
um i'm i just honored to know you from
chegg and the varkey foundation
congratulations
both my parents were teachers
they came to dubai in 1959 from kerala
as we were growing in dubai we only
thought it natural that as god has been
kind to you you know you also got to be
kind to the world and create a
structured way of giving and therefore
we we
formed the the barki foundation
the mission of the waki foundation is
that every
child deserves a good teacher
[Music]
since 2015 there have been 6 winners of
global teacher prize
and today
we will announce our 7th
all previous winners will tell you the
same thing
the greatest gift that global teacher
prides provides
is a seat
at the top table
a real voice
to make an impact
in our community
and far beyond
let's now take a look at the incredible
impact that each global teacher prize
winner has made since lifting up this
wonderful trophy
i was delighted honored and just shocked
pope francis announced my name i felt
like i had wings
i mean the announcement came from the
space station and it felt out of this
world maggie mcdonnell it's like time
stood still and i'll never forget that
moment andrea zafiraku
[Applause]
i still remember the moment i never
imagined this could happen in real to be
a global teacher prize arena
the world needs great teachers to grow
great minds that's why
we have created a million dollar prize
the global teacher prize gave us this
incredible platform to shine a spotlight
on the hundreds of thousands of stories
of incredible teachers that are making a
difference day in day out in the lives
of their students and in the lives of
their communities
what the global teacher prize did was it
gave me a sense of community with
teachers
all around the world the platform itself
the power it has i don't think can be
defined financially
after winning the global teacher prize
that created so many opportunities and
privileges i visited the over office met
the president of the united states of
america i've also had an opportunity to
address world economic forum world bank
united nations general assembly
the way society community the media
government has responded that's what the
biggest impact i think i had been
invited as advisor to world bank's
global coach program oecd has also
appointed me as their advisor for the
climate change programs
[Music]
maggie mcdonnell on behalf of all
canadians from one teacher to another
congratulations on winning the global
teacher prize 2017. my students since
winning the prize have traveled with me
to chile to argentina to iceland to
norway they've met with prime ministers
and spoke at the united nations
global teacher prize allowed me to talk
about my experience on harvard helsinki
cambridge
on behalf of everyone in the united
kingdom my warmest congratulations to
andrea zafiraku on winning the global
teacher prize my parents came to the
palace my husband came to the palace my
daughters and they met you know the
royal family you can't buy moments like
that i get quite a lot of those
incredible opportunities because of the
prize
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations to all the global
teacher prize winners
soon we will announce the winner of the
global title price 2021
and we look forward to seeing how they
will use this incredible platform
but first
i'm very excited to talk to the top 10
finalists
from 121 countries we received over 8
000 nominations and applications
and now we have 10 finalists they have
been selected based on how they improve
student outcomes innovate introduce
scalable practices share their knowledge
make an impact in the community and
develop global citizens
all over the world from europe to latin
america to africa working in cities
villages and even in the mountains but
they all share one very special quality
they are all dreamers
they all believe that a better world is
possible which is why they work so hard
to give their students the chance to
make a difference
prepare to be inspired
let's watch the heroic journeys of our
top 10 finalists
[Music]
[Music]
is
for me it's about engagement and that's
what i've been able to see in my
students people protect what they love
and so i just want them to fall in love
with the environment
i hope that by planting that seed early
on with them it leads them to also be
caring adults who continue to contribute
to the world
[Music]
there's so many ways we can improve the
world and we can start it in the
classroom
deep in my heart i'd like to be a
teacher for the rest of my life
i'd like to be a change maker
[Applause]
st vincent school is unique in itself
because it is only one of four schools
in the united kingdom set up for
curriculum for children with a visual
impairment we have a number of students
who represent their country and i've
been able to travel the world with their
skills at paralympic level
it's making our students aware of global
issues and that they can have a voice
[Music]
after my university education i was sent
to soyuz law business they were
struggling with truancy especially
students avoiding mathematics class with
the help of the technology that i use in
teaching students enjoy learning
mathematics and so the idea of run away
from class actually
[Music]
the professor
[Music]
um
every child deserves a champion an adult
who will never ever give up on them who
insists that they become the best they
can possibly be
the students i teach remind me so much
myself their stories are my story
i'm willing to go above and beyond for
my students because at the end of the
day their success is my success
we make sure that our students
understand all of the concepts around
the globe that could impact the future
for themselves and other people around
the world
i firmly believe that our future leaders
are right here in our classrooms and the
way that we can make the world a better
place is by giving them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
10 truly remarkable human beings
so let's meet them
it is my great pleasure to introduce the
top 10 finalists of the global teacher
prize 2021.
here they are beaming in from every
corner of the planet from argentina
australia canada france ghana iran
mexico philippines the united kingdom
and the united states of america
first of all
let's meet anna from argentina
anna
how does it feel to be a finalist
yesterday
thank you anna brianna from canada how
are you doing hello from canada i'm
wonderful thank you
next it's time to meet bryan from the
philippines hi
i'm from la palace philippines
hi to everyone wonderful i know your
country very well by the way
from the united kingdom let's meet david
hello one way from liverpool and it's
lovely to be here thank you
and for you how does it feel to be a
finalist david
it's wonderful to be a families and it's
extremely overwhelming you can be very
proud
and from mexico diana a warm welcome to
you how are you
hello i'm really good i feel very happy
and excited but very inspired for all of
my
partners thank you so much
next up we have evans from ghana
it's night being part of this great um
community of teachers
and i feel annette and thanks to bhakti
foundation for giving out this great
platform to sohai
wonderful thank you evans
next we have julene in france how are
you feeling julian i'm very excited and
very happy to be uh
in part of this and it's wonderful to to
meet passionate teachers all around the
world
you bet
thank you very much julina now let's
welcome keshia from the usa how does it
feel to be a finalist it feels
extraordinary to be a part of such a
great league of extraordinary teachers
i'm so happy and grateful to the market
foundation for acknowledging us and just
pushing us in the spotlight to tell our
stories thank you
thanks to you
all the way from australia we have
rebecca
how are you feeling right now i'm very
excited and grateful to be able to
showcase the wonderful things that
teachers do and to be able to learn from
the other finalists as well thank you
rebecca and last but not least from iran
a very warm welcome to you soraya
my name is
thank you top 10 finalists
so now we have met our 10 finalists it
can only mean one thing
that we're almost ready for the moment
you have all been waiting for
but before we announce the winner of the
global teacher prize 2021
we would like to present a special
musical performance i would like to
introduce 13-year-old singer and pianist
naomi aye
a shining star whose wonderful talent
shows us what young people can do
naomi became a viral sensation for her
interpretation of queen's bohemian
rhapsody from the voice kids friends
dedicated to the bravery of teachers and
students everywhere
naomi has chosen to sing courage to
change by sia
[Music]
i want to leave you better
i want my life to matter i am afraid i
have no purpose
here
i watch the news on tv
abandon myself daily
i am afraid to let
[Music]
we don't have to stay
stuck in the weeds
have i
the courage to change have i
the courage to change
the course to change
[Music]
the currency
[Music]
i want my life to matter i am afraid i
have no purpose
[Music]
you're not alone in all this and now on
our promised and then together we can do
anything
[Music]
thank you naomi for that wonderful
tribute to the world's teachers and
students
and now
we reach the climax of this year's
ceremony
the moment where we announced the winner
of the global title prize 2021
where we honor a truly exceptional
teacher
that has made an outstanding
contribution to the profession
and of course
with the title comes a one million
dollar award
the winner
of the global teacher prize 2021
is
keshia thorpe from the united states of
my
america
[Laughter]
[Music]
huge congratulations keshia
before i invite you to say a few words
we have a special congratulatory message
from ben ki-moon who served as the 8th
secretary general of the united nations
and is now the founder of the ban
ki-moon center for global citizens
congratulations
keshia thought
on this incredible achievement
this is a testament to your hard work
and sacrifice over many years
you have changed the lives of your
students who are first generation
americans
immigrants and refugees
you have shown them the life-changing
potential of a good education and you
have opened the door to their futures
you now have an incredible gift and
opportunity you have the chance to
become an international ambassador for
education
and to help others learn
from your success
this is important because
with a huge problems we face today
we don't just need to expand education
we also need to reimagine education
today our international community is
asking itself fundamental questions
about how it should face global threats
like the kobe 19 pandemic and climate
change
but your achievements
illustrate the simple truth that
education
is a single most effective way
to prepare the next generation to face
these challenges and the others that
they will surely face
education empowers people to fight
against injustice
look after their health develop green
technologies
boost opportunities for women
and choose peace over conflict
governments must make education a
priority
however without teachers like you
that work would all be for nothing
but tonight
is your night
and you should celebrate
once again my why mr congratulations to
you your students and your school
they will all share in your success
i'm certain that you will make them very
proud
thank you
thank you ben ki-moon for that powerful
message
keshia
i would now like to invite you to say a
few words the world is listening
thank you god for this proud moment it
is an honor to be chosen to be the
global teacher prize winner to mr sunny
varkey the varkey foundation and unesco
thank you for your leadership and vision
in spotlighting and honoring the great
work teachers across the globe are doing
and to elevate the status of the
teaching profession to my distinguished
guests my fellow top 10 the top 50
league of extraordinary teachers and all
teachers across the globe i recognize
you for being so relentless in ensuring
that all children you teach have the
opportunity to access and experience a
quality education that will prepare them
for a better way of life to my wonderful
supportive family my country my school
i also recognize you
education is a human right and all
children should be entitled to have
access to it so this recognition is not
just about me
but about all the dreamers who work so
hard and dare to dream of ending
generational poverty
this is to encourage every little black
boy and girl that looks like me and
every child in the world that feels
marginalized and has a story like mine
and felt they never matter
we must ensure all students have the
opportunity to succeed and no laws our
policy should treat them of that
this is also for every teacher across
the globe who shows up every day in the
classroom to teach their students and
transform their lives every child needs
a champion an adult who will never ever
give up on them who understands the
power of connection and insist they
become the very best they can possibly
be and this is exactly why teachers will
always matter
teachers matter
thank you
thank you kecia
i'd now like to ask you a few questions
firstly
how does this moment feel and what does
it mean for you
as a young girl
um from coming from the circumstances
that i come from i would never have
thought that something like this ever
happened to me i
i'm i'm i'm speechless i'm overjoyed i'm
amazed i'm
this is just an extraordinary
accomplishment for me and this validates
everything that i've done in my life up
to this point and i just thank god for
this moment
and you now have this incredible
platform a new voice in global education
what do you hope to achieve in the weeks
and months ahead
i want to be able to use this platform
to gain a seat at the table to advocate
at the highest level for my students
because they deserve it every student
deserves the right to an education and
i want to be that person who championed
that for them
thank you keshia
and thank you for all the incredible
work you do and the inspiration you
provide
that now concludes the seventh global
teacher prize ceremony
i would like to thank everyone that has
taken the time to tune in
we like to leave you with some of the
messages that are coming in from around
the world
congratulations keshia for extraordinary
achievements
and so it leaves me to thank her
and every single teacher in the world
after all
teachers like the path to a brighter
future
[Music]
on behalf of education cannot wait and
all who care about education let me
offer my warmest congratulations to
keisha for winning the 2021 global
teacher prize keisha's inspirational
story reminds us of the critical
importance of teachers and education
particularly in these difficult times
let us fight for education and for the
future of every child
i am delighted to congratulate jeremiah
thronker
a syrian union for winning the 2021
global student prize
he has dedicated himself to improving
his community
his country
and to addressing issues like pollution
and climate change
congratulations jerry mayer
it gives me enormous pleasure
to congratulate miss kasia thorpe for
winning the 2021 global teacher prize
the story has so much to tell us
about the need for courage and sacrifice
in the face of adversity but most of all
about the importance of education and
teachers
congratulations keshia torte for your
incredible achievement and it's because
of teachers like you not afraid to roll
up your sleeves go into the classroom
with your commitment your passion and
bring them on with you that makes a
difference in this world i'm very proud
of you well done
[Music]
you